Donald Trump has commuted the sentence
of his campaign associate Roger stone
Roger stone therefore will not be going
to prison where he was scheduled to
report soon now
there's the general discussion here and
then there's the specific discussion and
I think it makes sense to go in that
order in general when presidents
pardoned people or commute their
sentences it's very common that red
flags come up about connections between
the presidents and the people they are
pardoning or whose sentences they're
commuting a were they friends or
whatever the case may be
in this case Trump is commuting the
sentence not just of a friend to the
extent that Donald Trump has friendships
but of a friend who worked to get Donald
Trump elected but it isn't just that
it's a friend whose crime was directly
related to helping to get Donald Trump
elected but it's even more the reason
that Roger stone lied in relation to his
work getting Donald Trump elected was to
protect Trump by hiding wrongdoing that
Donald Trump may have been involved in
and in comes Donald Trump and commutes
Roger stones sentence this is exactly as
Republican senator Mitt Romney of all
people said it is historic corruption
Roger stone was a go-between for the
Trump campaign and WikiLeaks Roger stone
was materially involved in the Trump
campaign Roger stone was convicted by a
jury for lying to Congress to protect
Donald Trump so this is corruption this
is an abuse of power this is a quid pro
quo remember that phrase that Trump
threw around to stay strong
when it was Paul Manafort and Michael
Cohen Trump's former campaign chairman
and former personal lawyer who were
under investigation and under indictment
Donald Trump tweeted about mana Fortis
staying strong what that means is he's
protecting Donald Trump well Roger
stones stayed strong in that
he didn't roll over he didn't talk about
what Trump knew and what Trump did and
that is a quid pro quo this is arguably
a form of bribery this is arguably an
impeachable offense now Trump and others
will argue and it's important to be
prepared for this they will say the
president's power to pardon and commute
sentences is absolute yeah it's absolute
in that a president can pardon whoever
they want to pardon or commute the
sentence sentence of whoever they want
to commute a sentence for but that
doesn't mean that it can't also be an
act of corruption or a quid pro quo or a
form of bribery and only two Republicans
so far have actually called this out for
what it is one is MIT Romney as I
mentioned MIT Romney tweeted quote
unprecedented historic corruption an
American president commutes the sentence
of a person convicted by a jury of lying
to shield that very president now you
know good for Mitt Romney
but remember Romney voted to convict
Trump on one impeachment count but he
voted to acquit Donald Trump on
obstruction and now MIT Romney is
indignant that Donald Trump is again
obstructing give me a break so I get it
MIT Romney is saying things most
Republicans aren't willing to say but at
the same time you acquitted the guy on
obstruction you remember that right then
you have Republican Senator Pat Toomey
who said that the prosecution of Roger
stone was a righteous and appropriate
prosecution quoting what William bar had
to say and that if there was a problem
with this prosecution it really should
be resolved via an appeal not between
not by Donald Trump jumping in and
commuting the sentence of Roger stone if
Sohn was treated unfairly in a real
sense we are well within the scope of
time during which an appeal can be made
and it could actually be fought through
the courts so the action by Trump here
is not surprising the realization that
we've come to is that until Republicans
are forced to do what's right or stopped
from doing what's wrong they're going to
keep doing it and we're you know I think
maybe there's not that much I have to
say about stone specifically I think
it's basically all being been said but
what sometimes happens in these
situations is that some on the left will
start saying
should we stoop to their level like are
they so bad that we should resort to
cheating or violence or corruption in
order to get them out does the ends do
the ends justify the means and I don't
believe so I don't think that you can
pick and choose when to play by the
rules and obviously it's horrible right
now when we see the degree to which they
don't play by the rules
I understand saying it we would be
justified in not playing by the rules
here because we have to get them out I
think that that would be the wrong
instinct I believe the path forward
should be you've got to remove Trump in
November turn the Senate blue if not
this November in November of 2022 maybe
this terror of a presidency will affect
enough voters that it will sort of
predispose open up the country to accept
real change if the Democratic Party gets
the country back under control I'm no
fan of the Democratic Party as an
institution but you know there are
people who are going to seek to blame
Democrats here in fact I've seen some
so-called populist Sauveur the last week
finding as much to criticize of
Democrats in the context of the Trump
fiasco as they find to criticize about
Donald Trump himself I think they're
just wrong the truth is Democrats for
all of their faults and there are many
and I talk about them all the time
Democrats tried to investigate Trump
they saw facts which pointed to
impeachment being the right remedy and
they did it it didn't matter the
Republican Party was never going to go
for it we never believed for a second
that Trump was going to be convicted on
impeachment but the Democrats saw the
evidence and said impeachment is the
correct thing
Democrats were obstructed by the Trump
administration and by Republicans at
every turn so there are plenty of
critiques of the Democratic Party and I
make them all the time but right now
deflecting blame onto the Democratic
Party is the wrong move right now it's
the Republican Party under trumpism that
either participated in the attacks on
the rule of law or as they stood aside
as Trump did it himself and they need to
be held accountable as well that's very
important they are also to blame and you
primarily should be blaming the bad
actors so I'm not going to
play coy with that the way there are
some people doing New York maybe should
look at prosecuting Roger stone
president can't pardon or commute state
sentences and convictions so on the
stone matter that would be something to
look at but big picture we really can't
miss the forest for the trees right now